et alors que la ligne sécuritaire
adoptée par le président est de plus en
plus critique et donald trump se
retrouve-t-il isolé de son entourage
c'est l'objet de notre face à face et
pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec françois durpaire spécialiste des
états unis bonsoir françois durpaire à
ce bon soir comment ça va ça va très
bien et vous à ses côtés pâle rinne
président des républicains en frêne cela
remet donc à mériel bonsoir à vous paul
green également avec nous alors l'armée
américaine qui a fait savoir son
désaccord avec donald trump sur son rôle
possible pour faire face à ces
manifestations
donald trump quand même pas leur hymne
qui paraît de plus en plus isolé dans sa
gestion de la crise est ce que vous
craignez qu'ils soient lâchés n'ont pas
relâché il n'est pas isolé et s'est pas
tu la mets à américain qui est contre
cette décision c'est juste un an mama
cass de s'acquitter de france et je vais
essayer d'expliquer qu'il ya un
rapidement tu en as déjà déployés le
militaire
il a mille dix sept mille soldats de la
garde nationale en disposition pour les
états aux etats unis les états beaucoup
pouvoir
c'est eux qui doit être d'accord
d'utiliser le militaire ça c'est légal
national qui n'est pas le militaire
active le problème il ya déjà vingt
trois états qui a déployé les légats
nationale et le gars nationale c'est
qu'on soutient le police locale mais par
exemple à new york
oui il ya plus deux millions environ
jetons tous les autres vivent en ce
moment qui a refusé d'utiliser les gars
national de chambre c'est un peu
provocateur il ay la menace et que vous
avez bien dit d'utiliser cet acte d'une
direction pour activer le micatti des
marques aspect actuel de défense était
juste posé une question par la phase 6 a
dit que non il faut utiliser cet acte
insurrection juste un hic à tresques
13 juin pour le moment on n'est pas là
pour le moment c'est logique
françois durpaire est aussi optimiste
pour donald trump que par laurine parce
que même son ancien ministre de la
défense un jean mathis l'accusé je suis
de divisé l'amérique alors stéphanie
gelé ni optimiste ni pessimisme
simplement comme pas l'origine
oui oui mais pas politique
moi je suis pas républicain et je ne
suis pas démocrate et je voterai ni pour
un candidat ni pour l'autre et en plus
je suis français ça va pas changer ma
vie simplement pour l'analyser on
pourrait dire que oui pour la raison
c'est un homme mais c'est le secrétaire
à la défense
donc c'est pas un militaire c'est le
secrétaire à la défense est quand même
important que marque espère s'exprime de
cette manière là puis à une deuxième
chose c'est les propos de jean mathis
donc vous avez parlé l'ancien secrétaire
à la défense
ça veut dire que c'est au congrès et ça
veut dire qu'on peut tout dire de jean
mathis on peut tout dire de marque
espère on ne peut pas dire que ce ne
sont pas de bons républicains
on peut pas dire que ce sont pas de bons
conservateurs on ne peut pas dire non
plus qu'ils ne sont pas respectés dans
l'armée américaine
on peut pas dire non plus que jean
mathis n'est pas respectée au congrès
ayez pas respectés par les démocrates
il est respecté par les républicains et
par une partie des républicains
donc le problème pour donald trump ne
sait pas du pessimisme est simplement
que un problème possible c'est que jean
mathis vous l'avez vu aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui vous avez des républicains
qui sont interrogés nécessairement par
la presse quand vous êtes congressman
sénateur républicain qu'est ce que vaut
consoeurs et confrères américains vont
faire ils vont se jeter sur tous les
sénateurs eelv on l'a dit alors vous
êtes d'accord avec denain trappe ou vous
êtes d'accord avec jean mathis où vous
êtes d'accord avec marc et faire et ça
c'est pas très très très bon parce que j
mathis il est respecté ça fait des
années et des années que c'est confrères
au sénat ces républicains disent du bien
de jean mathis disent que c'est un bon
général disent que c'est un homme de
valeur et un homme qui a une autorité
qui est respecté donc c'est ça un peu
problème est ce que c'est un problème
insurmontable peut-être pas les
divisions autour de 30 on en connaît
depuis le début du mandat alors que
c'est là dessus qu'il va perdre alors
écoutez hausse compensant vous dites du
matisse qui est un homme respecté
notamment au congrès françois durpaire
l'écoutait ce qu'en pense donald trump
dans un tweet
la seule chose que barack obama et moi
avoue probablement en commun et que nous
avons tous les deux eu l'honneur de
revoyez jean mathis le général le plus
surestimé du monde
j'ai demandé sa lettre de démission et
je me sentais très bien son surnom était
ko que je n'aimais pas échangé en chien
fou à laurine tout de même à ce que
c'est comme ça qu'un président américain
doit répondre à un homme qui est
respecté aux états unis notamment par le
congrès oui mais c'est non c'est selon
chien fou ce n'était pas créer pas dans
notre chambre c'était son surnom depuis
2004 dans trente 30 disaient qu'il y là
à crier mais en fait il a il a préféré à
utiliser ce nom est en fait tout le
monde quand il parle de john holmes est
ici pas de chien sous mais donne sur
escrime etc
vous n'avez pas peur quand même qui
braque les gens en pleine campagne
présidentielle
non non pas du tout parce que les gens
qui suit les une fosse à l'histoire avec
tuner matzke en 2018 atchan pas voulu de
retirer des des troupes les sodas de
série à 2 minutes et métis n'était pas
d'accord il a voulu augmenter des
troupes tant qu'il avait un désaccord
est bon il juste avant son retrait a
décidé de ce prêt dirais enfin 2018 donc
c'est pas très grave mais notre odeur
qui était grave et écrite chez noma il
était fâché évidemment vite rempli à
green dans la critique dans une intrigue
gauche juste cette semaine où hier et
c'était vraiment très très surpris non
qu'il était en critiquant au président
il a dit qu'il te dit ce pays en fait
c'est la gauche qui depuis françois
durpaire même les réseaux sociaux
commencent un peu à tourner le dos au
président trump ans qui est quand même
pas à nous d'en notamment le rappel en
pleine campagne présidentielle le
dernier en date c'est ce match at qui
modère son tour ces messages nous
n'avons pas anti fier des voix qui
incitent à la violence raciale et
l'injustice ça pourrait quand même
marqué un tournant
compliqué pour le président américain
ont finalement c'est pas si grave alors
stéphanie là il faudrait une émission
complète pour et je suis sûr je suis sûr
qu'on va la faire on va leur faire cette
émission parce que vous savez les
rapports entre donald trump et les
plateformes
alors ce sont des plateformes ou sont-ce
des médias c'est un peu la question est
ce que twitter est un média et à ce
moment là il a raison de pouvoir
critiquer ou est ce que c'est une
plateforme et à ce moment là la
plateforme n'a pas à critiquer donna
train c'est un vrai débat de fond sur la
démocratie numérique ça se traite pas
évidemment quelques secondes c'est pas
que je botte en touche mais sinon c'est
important est-ce que c'est est-ce que ça
va être le sort de l'élection je pense
pas ce qui peut être le sort de
l'élection c'est ce qui se passe en ce
moment c'est que donald trump a besoin
de l'intégralité des votes républicaine
j'ai quasiment acquis mais attention
faut pas quand même qu'au congrès y ait
des voix discordantes comme c'est celle
qu'on a entendues au cours des dernières
heures
mais il a aussi besoin des votes
indépendante pour quelle raison parce
que vous savez il ya quelque chose qu'on
ne dit pas des joe biden c'est que joe
biden s'est peut-être pas le plus grand
candidat de l'histoire du parti
démocrate
mais il est moins clivant qu'hillary
clinton il est moins clivant qu'hillary
clinton ce qui est en train de se passer
en ce moment c'est sans être cynique
c'est peut-être une chance pour lui au
niveau des votes africaine américaine
et vous voyez bien qu'en ce moment il ya
quand même un climat un peu particulier
il ya un pays qui est profondément
divisée que ce soit les uns ou les
autres qui le divise le constat il est
là il ya un pays divisé qui va voter
dans quelques semaines et moi mon
intuition est mon analyse on va bien
c'est que le président le candidat qui
soit pendue qui soit président qui soit
candidat
qui parviendra à trouver les mots de
réconciliation de cette amérique va
gagner le vote indépendant et c'est le
vote indépendant qui va faire la
décision
un pari de votre analyse ya de
l'inquiétude de votre part quand même
avec effectivement cette gestion du coc
vite compliqué aux états unis cet
épisode jaune floyd qui n'est pas encore
terminée il ya de l'inquiétude pour vous
pour cette campagne
non pas tellement mais a toujours des
filles dans notre champ quand tous les
jours toutes les semaines
tu les presses et sont un titre en petit
et les fortes de gens qu'il est mort
pendant la corne est de dire que c'était
la faute d'être en maintenant les
émeutes sont un effort de charente à la
légion avec les problèmes économiques
mais tous ces sons base est toujours
solide
il se tient très bien le grand majorité
des américains de sache que il ne veut
pas de violence
ils sont contre les violences contre les
émeutes on était tous pour l'acné mme
anissa pacifique ont été tous pour que
aller les policiers raciste mais nos
soeurs deux sont mises en prison
mais les émeutes c'est une
malheureusement c'est une stratégie
politique fait parler par les démocrates
c'est vraiment stratégie politique et
joba hayden et parce que il ne condamne
pas de violence obama qui est en train
de parler maintenant et il condamne pas
il n'y pas arrêtées dont il veut que tu
exploses mails blâme se trompe et pour
gagner on a essayé de gagner en novembre
mais je crois que tu l'as toujours
gagner merci en tout cas tous les deux
pour